yeah welcome to this video playing
laurence went from germany and i think
this is a feeder master Lauren's back he
he played them in an imposing team just
last year and in the German leak and
gather some changa 400 s been an
interesting way to play as white if
black does not play d5 it is very decent
a line and this now is some very unclear
ok I'm going to play this sharply not
sure if this is a theoretical
theoretical line but it it looks som
like black should get some compensation
here blank Scott um yeah good
development and it's just hear it white
has a strange with North F form which in
this position doesn't make any sense at
all it's an f4 is the kind of move that
is very good or interesting if you
manage to get a slow build up if black
plays e66 and so on watch g6 then this
is quite interesting but after d5 it's
it's tricky I actually very much prefer
black okay so i can play it complicated
or yeah why not actually okay it does it
does sir okay i can take first on a for
many many ideas it's not it's not for
store oh at all what i would like
templayer i can also even take cannot
take b5 because a 8 hangs but
I was actually thinking of taking on c3
and play Queen d3 some also look at them
interesting to me it's not clear if it's
that the best line really Knight b6 is
also possible okay let's let's play move
not lose on time now what about Bishop
d7 actually on castles I have Bishop b5
but this is good c4 I can take with a
double attack a B and the rook so the
position um really opens up I like that
ya know I can play Bishop b5 there are
still a beehive if I take with the
bishop it would prevent castling for the
moment okay if he goes queen bee three i
play c4 probably i don't want the slow
move c4 night eggs okay I thought f6 now
actually get rid of this of the night
want to prevent him canceling yeah maybe
if this is what what I should have
considered considered more thoroughly
yeah this is no problem I don't have a
good square for the piece I can go to a
far though threatening quindi 193 FB
should see to which isn't entirely clear
anything but it's at least interesting
be 3 i'm just taking and this is some
just completely completely weird 93
bishop c2 is got kawin sistex check as
well okay so we have this completely
completely strange pawn structure if it
capsules a half Queen D for this is a
very useful of course maybe I should
just take that it's got Quincy 6
okay I need two planes I'm done on time
he's up upon if he takes only five yeah
I should just take that's right because
of Quincy six this is the the big
problem here 26 but maybe I can go King
the edge as weird as it looks King the
edge well maybe I mean I cannot go to to
have seven anyway because of you have
one check go in here so I just play King
the aid check what a weird position yeah
we cannot if you move to the bishop i'm
taking a one with check so it's not dead
easy yeah this rook is hanging it's not
clear where it should go you can play
Queen d5 check check so just bring the
king yeah this is interesting but i get
i get ecigs which is very important
check so even at once probably not
draw I try to get get pieces out as
quickly as possible this is some very
critical them down on time if he goes
through ji ho I can maybe take it with
your age 6 I'm material down that slits
obvious but age 6 yeah probably any way
to get to the second rank I have push-up
g7 to activate it yeah maybe this is
still still okay how to have the same
I'm just one porn down which is which is
more than I am which is better than a
then I feared just one phone
check time changes seconds check Graham
heart around I'm on 17 seconds and i'm
always up for some kind of weird stunts
but don't really think I should in this
position this was very critical probably
lost at some point yeah I had I had
underestimated this the c-4 idea of
course and here this is tricky this move
is just very strong and I have no no way
to to prevent it really the Sun this
also means that the whole approach is
says wrong I need to do something else
probably here at the latest or here I
mean this position is certainly okay
again I can play all kinds of moves in
60 or something I'll get the the bishop
any anyway at he's got this we had move
a 4 plate so it's it's compensation
anyway but what I did is is just too
ambitious and this is a very strong
response maybe I should have played
eight eggs beam but yeah maybe something
like that as weird as it looks but this
way I already got into trouble I mean
the computer even wants to play a 4 and
this wins straight away
not quite sure that I understand why a
TIG TIG yeah I cannot recapture yeah and
d4 of course before I don't have any
kind of Queen d4 idea and this means I'm
toast and Quincy 6 coming and short
castles okay I should have really lost
this game well I escaped being lucky
thanks for watching